Okay.
So having studied job,
we've seen that the Bible is not a book with a single uniform style and message.
It's an anthology of diverse works,
uh,
that may have different conflicting points of view.
So the con conventional religious piety of proverbs,
the firm belief in a system of divine reward and punishment that's so important
to the deuteronomist.
Um,
this is challenged by the book of job.
Job concludes that there is no justice,
not in this world,
not in any other world.
And nevertheless job feels that he is not excused from the task of righteous
living.
And it's a wonderful and fortuitous fact of history that Jewish sages chose to
include all of these dissonant voices in the Canon of the Hebrew Bible without,
for the most part striving to reconcile the conflicts.
And I mentioned this because I hope it will help you in writing your final
paper.
Um,
careful exegesis of the biblical text,
which is part of your task in these papers.
I'll come back in a minute too.
The other part of your task,
uh,
but careful exegesis of the biblical texts requires you to set aside your
presuppositions and to attend to the many complex and often conflicting details
of the text.
Some of the other presuppositions that you need to set aside when you write this
paper are presuppositions that I mentioned at the very outset of the course,
but it might be wise to mention a few of them.
Again.
The first is,
and I hope you've seen by now that the Bible is not a set of stories about
saints or pious people who always say and do what is right or exemplary,
right?
Even the Bible's heroes are,
are human.
They're not superhuman.
Their behavior can be confused.
It can be immoral,
and if we try to vindicate Biblical characters merely because their names appear
in the Bible,
we can miss the moral dilemma that's being set out by the writer.
We can miss the psychological complexity of the stories.
So when you do these papers,
put yourself in the place of the character.
In other words,
humanize them.
I think of them as,
as I think of them as acting in ways you might act.
Think about their likely feelings.
They're likely mode motivations as human beings.
Secondly,
remember that the Bible isn't a manual of religion.
It's not a book of systematic theology.
It doesn't set out certain dogmas about God and you need to be careful not to
impose upon the Bible theological ideas and beliefs that arose centuries after
the bulk of the Bible was written.
For example,
a belief in a heaven and hell is a system of reward or punishment or the belief
in a God that doesn't change his mind.
The character Yaffe white in the Bible changes his mind.
It's just a fact of the text.
If we wish to understand the Bible on its own terms and in its own context,
then we have to be prepared to find ideas in it that may conflict with later
theological notions that we hold dear and don't assume you're going to agree
with the Bible.
Don't assume that the Bible will agree with itself.
So then coming to your paper assignments,
you've been asked in a,
in the final paper assignment to develop an interpretation of a passage.
And the task of interpretation for the purposes of this class is not excavated.
In other words,
you're not asked to analyze sources or to account for how the text reached its
final form,
right?
Source criticism.
You're to look at the final form of the text and give a plausible reading that
makes the best sense that you can out of the details,
whether you like the meaning or not,
whether you agree with the meeting or not.
Try to argue from the evidence in the text itself.
So you're going to be doing what you're probably quite accustomed to doing in an
English class.
You're going to study the texts language.
It's vocabulary,
it's structured,
it's style,
all of the clues.
Look at the immediate context,
the larger context,
the way vocabulary is used elsewhere in the Bible,
similar vocabulary.
Um,
anything that might shed light on the passages meaning,
or a character's motivation.
And then you're going to weigh the evidence and present your reading.
And as in an English class,
you'll want to minimize any external assumptions that you bring to the text.
Anything that's not supported by the text.
And often the text will be truly ambiguous,
precisely because there are gaps of information or there are hints that pull in
two different directions at times.
That's part of the great artistry of the Biblical text.
That's what makes it so interpretable.
And if that happens,
then you may want to present various,
uh,
dueling interpretations,
various plausible interpretations of the passage based on the evidence and the
texts and say,
you know,
these sorts of things lead would lead one to suppose that this is going on.
But on the other hand,
these textual clues lead to the following,
you know,
a plausible interpretation of what's going on.
You'll find that the task of interpretation is easier if you keep in mind the
following point.
Not all statements in the Bible are equal when a story is being told,
information conveyed by the narrator is reliable.
Speech attributed to God is reliable.
The words of individual characters are not necessarily reliable.
Characters can be wrong.
They can be misguided.
They have limited perspective and sometimes the narrator hints as much.
Um,
but the voice of the narrator is privileged and that's part of the game we play
when we read works of Literature.
We accept facts that are established by the narrator as facts that guide our
interpretation.
And so it was with the story of job,
right?
The narrator established as a fact of the story.
That job is perfectly righteous.
That's in the narrator's voice.
In the pros introduction,
he states that explicitly he bolsters this statement by attributing the same
assertion to God and the narrator also establishes as a fact of the story that
Joe was afflicted with horrendous suffering that he didn't deserve.
It's not a punishment for sin and then he leaves the characters to struggle with
the implications.
Job's friends cling to the idea that God rewards and God punishes.
And so anyone who suffers must have sinned.
We as readers know that they are wrong because of the narrative facts
established at the beginning of the story.
Job takes the other row route.
He knows we do that he is innocent,
that he is not being punished for sin and therefore he concludes that God
doesn't punish and reward at all.
And that's a radical idea that God punishing the wicked and rewards the good in
this life,
even if a little delayed sometimes is a fundamental idea in much of the Bible
that we have studied so far,
it's getting,
it's going to get weaker.
And some of the books we'll be looking at,
but but job denies this idea and in doing so he arrives at a radical moral
conclusion.
The truly righteous man is righteous for its own sake,
even if his righteousness brings him nothing but suffering and pain in this life
or in any other.
And remember that at the end of the book,
the narrator has God's state.
That job is the one who has spoken rightly and not his friends.
So be sure to consider point of view and your interpretation.
You wouldn't want to go in and just lift something out of Bill Dad's mouth to
say,
this is what the Bible thinks,
right?
Taking a verse right out of context that way.
Don't assume that every character in the Bible is reliable.
Look to the surrounding framework as you evaluate their deeds and their actions
and their speech and their views,
and finally,
don't be surprised if after carefully looking at all of those things,
a passage remains ambiguous.
Again,
in those cases,
you might want to detail the features that would support interpretation a,
the features that would support interpretation be or you might plump for one
interpretation over the other.
That's the first part of your task.
It will help you enormously if you do that right,
it will help you enormously and by right,
I mean thoroughly.
I don't mean correct.
I mean,
right in the sense that if you do it well and thoroughly,
then it will help you enormously in the second part of your task,
which is to analyze a Jewish and a Christian and a Christian not or a Jewish and
a Christian interpretation of the passage,
particularly whatever key,
ambiguous point you might have found in it.
And try to understand how they are a reading of the text,
a genuine effort to deal with,
to grapple with probably the very points of ambiguity that you,
yourself found when you really delved into the text.
Right.
And as much as their answers may not be answers that you would come up with,
they are still genuine readings of the exact issues that bugged you when you
analyze the texts closely tried to give an account for that.
What is it that this interpretation chooses to,
um,
develop,
as it presents its interpretation?
What is it suppressing?
What does this interpretation suppressing?
What is it picking up on and developing?
Right?
And you'll be sensitive to those things because you will have invested the time
yourself and appreciating how complex the passages.
So do understand that you need to do all of those things for any of the four
questions.
Develop your own interpretation,
analyze a Jewish and a Christian interpretation of the same passage.
Okay,
now there is debate among scholars over the date of the book of job as well as
some of the other books of the two of Veem to Veem is the Hebrew word that
simply means writings and it's the label or the name that we use to refer now to
the third section of the Bible,
right?
So we've talked about Tara and the VA more profits and now we're moving into the
writings or we have already really moved into the writings.
The third section of the Bible,
most scholars would concur that many of these books contain older material,
right?
But that the books reached their final form,
their final written form only later,
uh,
in the post exit like period.
Now if these books contain material that predates the exile,
is it legitimate for us to speak of them and study them as a response to the
national calamities?
Um,
particularly the,
the destruction and defeat and exile five 87 and five of 86 and answer to this
question will consider a relatively recent approach to the study of the Bible.
It's an approach known as canonical criticism.
Canonical criticism grew out of a dissatisfaction with the scholarly focus on
original historical meanings to the exclusion of a consideration of the function
or meaning of biblical texts for believing communities in various times and
places,
right?
A dissatisfaction with a focus on original context and original meaning,
um,
to the exclusion of any interest in how the texts would have served a given
community at a later time.
A community for which it was canonical.
Right?
At what point did these stories and sources suddenly become canonical and have
authority for communities?
And when they did,
how were they read and understood and interpreted?
So the historical critical method was always primarily interested in what was
really said and done by the original biblical contributors.
Canonical criticism assumes that biblical texts were generated,
transmitted,
reworked,
and preserved in communities for whom they were authoritative.
And that biblical criticism should include study of how these texts functioned
in the believing communities that received and cherished them.
So emphasis is on the final received form of the text,
much less interest in how it got to be,
what it is more interested in how,
what it is now and um,
rather than the stages in its development,
there's a greater interest and emphasis and canonical criticism on the function
of that final form of the text in the first communities to receive it.
And on the processes of adaptation by which that community and later communities
would really signify earlier tradition to function authoritatively in a new
situation.
So a canonical critic might ask,
for example,
what meaning authority or value did a biblical writers seek in a tradition or
story when he employed it in the final form of his text?
What meaning authority or value,
what a community with his community have found in it and what meanings and
values would later communities fine in it?
When that text became canonical for them,
how did they re signify it to be meaningful for them?
Why did religious communities except what they did as canonical rather than
setting certain things aside,
why was something chosen as canonical and meaningful for them when it came from
an earlier time?
So I propose that we adopt this approach for many of the books.
In this third section of the Bible,
we look at the Bible through the eyes of the post exilic community for whom they
were canonical,
at least in part that we won't do this for everything.
But I'm going to be coming back to this approach many times in the last few
lectures because in this way it becomes possible for us to understand these
books as a response to the national history,
not in their genesis or origin.
They weren't written necessarily as responses to the national history.
Some of them may even predate the exile,
but in the fact that they were adopted or cherished as meaningful by the post
exhibit community.
So whatever the circumstances of their origin and final reduction might have
been.
Many of the books of the two VM of the writings eventually would serve the post
exit community as a prism through which to view Israel's history.
Interestingly,
many of the books in this section of the Bible explore questions of suffering
and evil and challenge.
Some of the ideas that we've seen is more fundamental in the Torah and the
prophets.
They explore the very questions that are raised by the events of Israel's
history.
And so they were appropriated by the community in its quest for meaning in the
midst of suffering
as turned to the book of Ecclesiastes.
These are co hell at the Hebrew name is co Helot.
ECCLESIASTES is,
it's a second attack on the optimism and piety of conventional religion.
Uh,
the book is mostly in the first person.
There's a third person introduction and a little epilogue.
The introduction reads the words of [inaudible],
son of David King in Jerusalem.
Now Co hell,
it may mean preacher and that's why the Greek translation Ecclesiasticus,
which means preacher.
Um,
it's hard to know one who assembles or gathers others,
but tradition attributes the work to David's son Solomon known for his wisdom.
This attribution is fictive.
I'm the writer speaks of King's raining before him.
That implies there were many but more important,
there are linguistic and literary features that suggest a later,
probably more perhaps a fourth century date,
so as such,
the work can be understood as a post destruction and a post exists like work.
It was available to Israelites who were struggling to make sense of their
history and their God even though no reference is made to that history at all
and in fact God is not referred to by his personal Israelite name.
Yeah,
halfway in the book at all.
He's only referred to with the general term Elohim.
The prominent tone of the book is one of alienated,
a cynicism and a wiry melancholy.
It's the prominent tone.
The theme that's repeated throughout is the idea of the emptiness of human
effort.
All is vanity means few tile.
It's all for not co at one one utter futility said Co helot utter futility,
all is futile.
What real value is there for a man in all the gains he makes beneath the sun.
One generation goes,
another comes,
but the earth remains the same forever.
And in verse nine,
only that shall happen which has happened only that occur which has occurred.
There is nothing new beneath the sun.
The endless repeated cycles of the natural world,
the rising and setting of the sun and moon,
the ebb and flow of the tides.
This leads the um,
speaker to the conclusion that everything is that nothing is permanent.
All is fleeting change constantly in any,
uh,
we don't find in Cohasset the linear view of time or the sense of progress in
history that scholars rightly or wrongly associate with the Hebrew Bible.
We find here instead the sick click view of time,
which scholars again,
rightly or wrongly associate with myth.
There are also the endlessly repeated cycles of human,
of the human world,
birth and death,
breaking down and building up weeping in laughter,
love and hate killing and healing.
And one of the most famous passages from this book now co Hell.
It expresses the idea that everything has its season or time with the
consequence that the effort of humans to alter or affect anything is
meaningless.
I'm going to be reading from the RSV translation and in fact many of the things
I'll be reading today will be from the RSV revised standard version because I
think many of these passages will be familiar to you and I'd rather read
versions that will catch your ears as familiar then the more accurate
translations of Jewish publication society,
but which may not ring that that familiar a note for you.
So this is the RSB translation.
But notice how in context it has a very different meaning from the meaning
that's been granted it by folk singers,
for everything.
There is a season and a time for every matter under heaven,
a time to be born in a time to die,
a time to plant and a time to pluck up what is planted,
time to kill and a time to heal,
a time to break down and a time to build up,
a time to weep.
And a time to laugh,
a time to mourn,
and a time to dance,
a time to cast away stones and a time to gather stones together.
A time to embrace and a time to refrain from embracing a time to seek an a time
to lose,
a time to keep and a time to cast away.
A time to rand and a time to sow.
A time to keep silent and a time to speak.
A time to love and a time to hate.
A time for war and a time for peace.
Switching now to the jps translation.
What value then can the man of affairs get from what he earns?
I have observed the business that God gave man to be concerned with.
He brings everything to pass precisely at its time.
In other words,
everything comes to pass and returns and endless cycles.
We add nothing by our efforts.
It's not quite the comforting,
uh,
comforting passage that it's often quoted to be.
So the writer has tried everything in his search for something that's permanent
and not evanescent physical pleasure,
he says is unsatisfying.
It's transient.
Wealth just brings anxiety.
Wisdom is better than power,
but even knowledge brings great pain one 17 and 18 and so I set my mind to
appraise wisdom and to appraise madness and folly and I learned that this too
was pursuit of wind for as wisdom grows,
vexation grows to increase learning is to increase heartache.
Don't believe him.
Even if we concede that wisdom is superior to ignorance,
we must still face the fact that ultimately death obliterates everything,
death is the great equalizer.
Go hell it to 13 to 17 I found that wisdom is superior to folly as light as
superior to darkness.
A wise man has his eyes and his head where as a fool walks in darkness,
but I also realized that the same fate awaits them both.
So I reflected the fate of the fool is also destined for me to what advantage
then have I been wise and I came to the conclusion that that too was few tile
because the wise man just like the fool is not remembered forever for as the
succeeding days roll by,
both are forgotten.
Alas,
the wise man dies just like the fool.
And so I loathed life for,
I was distressed by all that goes on under the sun because everything is few
tile and pursuit of wind,
so even more explicitly than job Ecclesiastes,
these attacks the principle of divine providence or distributive justice,
there's no principle of reward or punishment.
The wicked prosper while the innocent suffer and even the principal of delayed
punishment,
which is so important to the Deuteronomistic historian is attacked,
is unjust and [inaudible] eight versus 10 beat of 14 and here's another
frustration.
The fact that the sentence imposed for evil deeds is not executed swiftly,
which is why men are emboldened to do evil.
The fact that a sinner may do evil a hundred times and it's punishment still be
delayed.
Sometimes an upright man is requited according to the conduct of the Scoundrel
and sometimes the scoundrel is required according to the conduct of the upright.
I say all that is frustration and in a more famous passage,
chapter nine 11 and 12 I have further observed under the sun that the race is
not won by the swift nor the battle by the Valeant,
nor is bread one by the wise nor wealth by the intelligent nor favor,
by the learned for the time of miss chance comes to all and a man cannot even
know his time.
Again,
a passage which is often used as a comforting exhortation.
You know the battle at the,
the race is not won by the swift and so on.
It's here actually in context.
I'm a lament of the great injustice of the way things occur,
but really for Helen it is the inexorable fact of death that makes life entirely
meaningless and that is in fact the starting point of modern schools of
existentialist death is the bottom line.
He rejects the idea of any life after death.
A chapter nine verses two through six for the same fate is in store for all,
for the righteous and for the wicked,
for the good and pure and for the impure.
For Him who sacrifices and for him who does not,
for him,
who is pleasing.
And for him he was displeasing and for him who swears and for him who shuns
oaths.
And that is the sad thing about all that goes on under the sun,
that the same fate is in store for all four.
He who was reckoned among the living has something to look forward to since the
living.
No,
they will die.
It was ironic,
but the dead know nothing.
They have no more recompense for even the memory of them has died.
Their loves,
their hates their jealousies of long since perished and they have no more share
till the end of time and all that goes on under the sun.
Nevertheless,
despite all of this despair and cynicism,
there is a positive note in Cohasset.
The writer after all doesn't recommend neorealism or suicide despite the lack of
purpose or meaning in life.
And in fact he does quite the opposite.
He states that every life does have its moments of happiness and these one
should seize while one can go highlit nine verses seven through 10 go eat your
bread in gladness.
And drink your wine and joy for your action was long ago,
approved by God.
Let your clothes always be freshly washed and your head never lacked ointment
and joy.
Happiness with a woman you love,
all the fleeting days of life that had been granted to you under the sun.
All your fleeting days for that alone is what you can get out of life and out of
the means you acquire under the sun,
whatever it is in your power to do,
do with all your might for there is no action,
no reasoning,
no learning,
no wisdom and Shay ole where you are going.
And again,
she all refers to this shadowy placed beneath the soil that the shades of the
dead just in habit.
Um,
and that's an ancient notion in Israel.
It's,
it's not connected with the idea of a reward or a punishment after death.
A similar,
um,
exhortation is in Kohala at five or 17.
Behold,
what I have seen to be good and fitting is to eat and drink and find enjoyment
and all the toil with which one toils under the sun the few days of his life,
which God has given him for this is his lot or three 13.
Whenever a man does eat and drink and get enjoyment out of all his wealth,
it is a gift of God.
We have to be sure not to dilute ourselves.
There is no grand plan.
There's no absolute value or meaning to our toil co hell.
It says there's no life in the here.
After that we are working towards and here he seems to be polemicizing I think
against the belief in the afterlife or reward or punishment that was taking root
at this time in some parts of the Jewish community under the influence of Greek
thought.
But one can still find happiness and love.
And with these one should be content striving after anything more is a striving
after wind that leaves one frustrated and weary and bitter.
Accept the reality of death and then enjoy what you can and the short time you
have.
Indeed,
it's precisely the reality of death that makes life precious.
Whatever it is in your power to do do with all your might because you have only
this one brief chance.
Eternal unlimited life with endless opportunities to act would make any one act
meaningless.
So given the fact of death and the limitations that it places upon us taking
pleasure in the ordinary activities in labors of life becomes not meaningless
but meaningful co hell.
It is an unusual if not subversive book and its inclusion in the Canon was
apparently a matter of some controversy.
It's controversial.
Character is reflected in the pious editorial postscript that appears at the end
of the book.
The very end of chapter 12 verses 11 through 13 we read the following.
The sayings of the wise are like goads like nails fixed in prodding sticks.
They were given by one shepherd,
a further word against them.
My son be warned.
The making of many books is without limit and much study is a weariness of the
flesh,
the sum of the matter.
When all is said and done,
revere God and observe his commandments.
For this applies to all mankind,
that God will call every creature to account for everything unknown,
be it good or bad to fear God and obey his commandments because he will reward
the good and punish the evil is simply not the message of the book of
[inaudible].
It's very likely in my view,
people will disagree,
but it's very likely that this line comes from a later hand which was disturbed
by the theme of Co helots preaching.
So we have juxtapose then two responses to the suffering and pain in the world
and specifically the tragedy that befell Israel.
One,
an assertion of God's Providence and justice observe urging obedience and the
other and assertion of the lack of justice and providence in the world.
Preaching simple existential pleasures as a source of life's meaning and the
frustration of trying to make sense out of what has happened and the richness of
the Hebrew Bible derives precisely from its placement together of radically
diverse points of views like these points of view like these.
I'm going to turn now to the book of Psalms,
which we will probably not quite finished today.
Um,
but the book of Psalms contains a,
the principal collection of religious lyric poetry in the Bible consists of 150
poems,
uh,
most of which are prayers addressed to God.
Uh,
in a very nice little essay on the psalms.
There's a woman,
Margaret and duty who recounts a wonderful dialogue that takes place in
Charlotte.
Bronte's novel Jane Eyre.
You have the 10 year old Jane.
She's a very honest,
um,
but ms treated child and she's being interviewed by Brocklehurst who is this
very harsh school master.
And Jane recounts the conversation like this.
Do you read Your Bible sometimes with pleasure?
Are you fond of it?
And I liked revelation and the book of Daniel and Genesis and Samuel and a
little bit of exodus and some parts of kings and chronicles and job and Jonah
and the psalms.
I hope you like them.
Oh no sir.
No shocking.
I have a little boy younger than you who knows six psalms by heart.
And when you ask him,
which he would rather have a gingerbread nut to eat,
or a verse of a Psalm to learn,
he says,
oh,
the verse of a song,
Angels Sing.
Psalm says,
he,
I wish to be a little angel here below.
And he then gets to nuts in recompensed for his infant piety.
Psalms are not interesting.
I remarked that proves you have a wicked heart.
So Margaret and duty has pointed out,
I think some,
some set several interesting aspects to this dialogue.
And first she points out the literary authority and individual taste that's
exhibited by Jane.
She likes prophetic books with dramatic apocalyptic imagery.
She likes revelation and Daniel,
which we'll see soon,
is very dramatic and apocalyptic.
And then she likes rich narrative texts and histories.
Genesis Samuel,
parts of exodus,
I can probably pick out which parts,
uh,
kings chronicles.
And then she likes the stories of the trials of great survivors of tribulation
like Jane herself job and Jonah and Brocklehurst is looking for evidence of her
piety.
And instead he finds evidence of her distasteful love of drama and story and
imagery and suffering.
And he's quite shocked.
A pious child would naturally love the psalms,
which in Brocklehurst mind are the songs of angels and they teach humility and
reverence and his own pious child knows how to recite the psalms.
Jane's not impressed.
She obvi obviously sees through the sun's a little game even if Brocklehurst
does it and she says psalms aren't interesting and he's mortified.
Jane's lack of interest in the psalms.
Her preference for what duty?
Cause uh,
the raw and the reel is proof of her wickedness,
but Brocklehurst his perception of the Book of Psalms,
which I think many people share,
um,
is not an entirely accurate one.
And if Jane were to look closely,
she would find plenty of emotion and drama and suffering in the psalms as well.
Um,
the title psalms derives from the Greek Samoy.
It denotes,
um,
religious songs that are performed to musical accompaniment,
the musical accompaniment of the cell Teriana.
That's a string musical instrument.
So they imagined that these were performed to this accompaniment and som away.
And it's the scent to against translation of the Hebrew title to helium.
That Hebrew titled to helium probably means or does mean praises.
The psalms were only collected into a large anthology in the post exhilarate
period.
We can be pretty sure of that,
the fifth or the fourth century,
but many,
many particularly those that are attributed to professional temple musical
guilds are thought to have been used in the temple service.
Many of them date from very early preexist like times the temple staff provided
the psalms with musical and liturgical,
um,
notations,
I don't mean musical notes,
but I mean,
uh,
words indicating some sort of musical or liturgical use.
And those are preserved for us in the text.
We don't for the most part really know what they mean.
Their technical,
um,
some superscription and notes seem to be telling us the tune or the kind of
musical accompaniment for the SOM,
whether it was on stringed instruments or flutes.
Most of the psalms really tell us very little.
However,
about the time,
um,
and circumstances of their composition,
several it seems were um,
to be used at royal coronations,
which would mean that they were written when Davidic kings still ruled in
Jerusalem.
Psalm 45 is an example of a love song that's written in celebration of the
king's marriage with a form bride.
So this is also a of preexist like date.
So Psalm 45 verses 11 through 18 this would have been sung probably at a royal
wedding.
Take Heed,
lasts and note.
Incline your ear.
Forget your people and your father's house and let the king be aroused by your
beauty.
Since he is your Lord.
Bow to him.
Oh,
Tyrian last.
So she's from tire to the north.
The wealthiest people will court your favor with gifts,
goods of all sorts.
The royal princess,
her dress embroidered with golden mountings is led inside to the king maidens in
her train.
Her companions are presented to you.
They are led in with joy and gladness.
They entered the palace of the king.
Your sons will succeed,
your ancestors,
you will appoint them princess throughout the land.
I commemorate your fame for all generations,
so people's will praise you forever and ever so clearly.
Some of the psalms date to the period of the monarchy and scholars divide the
psalter into five main collections.
Each of them concludes with like a little duck salad you that indicates that
it's the end of a section.
So I've listed the sections down here,
sort of five books within the larger book of Psalms.
Um,
the latest of these probably go somewhat in chronological order.
So we think number five for example,
is probably the latest of the group because it's the one where,
um,
the manuscripts that were found at Qumran,
show the greatest variation,
which suggests that they had continued fluid for some time before being finally
fixed.
The second book,
book two,
so about halfway through the psalms,
right at the end of number 72 book two concludes with this postscript,
the prayers of David,
the son of Jesse are ended.
So at one time the Davidic psalms were thought to end.
They're almost all of the psalms in book one are prefaced with the phrase two or
of David.
The harder the particle in in Hebrew can be ambiguous probably of David.
And to this old first temple nucleus,
you had other collections then gravitating.
So,
for example,
all of the psalms between one 20 and one 34,
they all bear the same title,
a song of a sense.
They were songs that were probably sung by pilgrims on pilgrimage to Jerusalem
because from any direction you go into Jerusalem and you have to go up.
Um,
and so you go up to Jerusalem.
Nevertheless,
tradition attributes the entire book of Psalms to King David.
And that attribution stems from the fact that 73 of the 150 psalms are
explicitly said to be psalms of David.
And David is also in the historical books said to be a man of musical talent,
right.
So,
um,
the superscription is however,
are in many cases late additions.
So perhaps the psalms can only be said to be of David or Davidic if by that term
we mean that they are the result of royal patronage,
um,
or royal patronage of poetry by the House of David.
In general,
the Biblical text itself lists other authors for some of the psalms.
So 72 is ascribed to Solomon.
Number 90 is described in Moses.
Others are described to us stuff.
And the sons of Korah,
Caracas,
an ancestor of a priestly family,
some of them are clearly post exit,
like I'm number 74 laments the destruction of the temple,
number one 37 by the rivers of Babylon.
There we sat,
sat and wept as we thought of Xeon clearly from the perspective of the exile.
So what we have is an anthology and then theology of religious expressions
deriving from many centuries of Israel's history.
So despite the claim of religious tradition that the psalms were penned by
David,
uh,
it's clear that they were not all pinned by David.
Some of the psalms are oriented toward community worship.
Some of them are oriented more to individual worship.
But in ancient Israel,
there really isn't always a sharp distinction between the two.
The ancient Israelite in the temple,
uh,
prayed to God as a member of a larger community,
bound by a covenant and not as alone individual.
So in the words of Psalm 34,
three,
uh,
we read,
exalt the Lord with me,
let us extol his name together.
So there was a communal aspect,
too much worship.
A good deal of form critical work has been done on the book of Psalms.
We haven't spent a lot of time on form criticism.
It's another tool,
another approach that you is used in studying the text.
But the pioneer in this area was a man named Hormone Herrmann Gungko.
I think I've mentioned him before.
His work,
particularly in the book of Psalms,
was forwarded by Sigmund Moe Winkle.
Form.
Critics look at the forms that are used in the construction of Psalms and they
classify psalms according to their forms or their literary genre,
if you will.
And then the attempt to place these literary types or genres within their cultic
setting or their sits in Laban,
you know,
what would have been the circumstances under which such a psalm would have been
written or performed in general,
the psalms can be categorized formally and thematically and a number of
different ways.
And I've,
I've given you a handout which presents some broad classifications of form or
genre.
I've actually collapsed many of the main forms into several broader groupings.
But,
um,
the very serious form critics will give you upwards of 13,
14,
15 or more different forms for the psalms.
And as I say,
I've,
I've group many of them together.
As you see on the sheet,
I'm going to go through each one of these and give you some examples and talk
about some of the themes as well as the formal characteristics in the psalms.
So you'll see the variety that's contained in the [inaudible] first looking at
some hymns of praise.
These include creation,
hymns,
praise,
and God is the creator of the natural world.
Um,
psalms of Thanksgiving and psalms of trust.
These are really the largest category of psalms and probably are what give
Brocklehurst the impression that he has.
Many of them celebrate God's Majesty.
God's wisdom has power,
uh,
such as this creation him.
This is eight.
And by the way,
the numbers are just giving you some examples.
This is not exhaustive.
I didn't go through and,
and put every one of the hundred and 50 psalms.
But to give you an idea of an example of each category,
and I'll be drawing from these numbers.
So number eight Oh lord our Lord.
How majestic is your name throughout the earth?
You who have covered the heavens with your splendor.
When I behold your heavens,
the work of your fingers,
the moon and stars that you set in place,
what is man that you have been mindful of him,
mortal man that you have taken note of him and Adorn Him with glory and majesty?
You have made him master over your handiwork,
laying the world at his feet,
sheep and oxen,
all of them,
and wild beasts to the birds of the heavens,
the fish of the sea,
whatever travels the paths of the sea.
Oh Lord our Lord.
How majestic is your name throughout the earth?
It's a tiny little psalm.
Psalm one 17 that's just two verses long and it contains really all of the
classic formal elements of a psalm of praise or thanksgiving.
You have an opening invocation to worship I calling others to worship or praise
God.
Then you have a motive clause which is giving the reason and then a
recapitulation or a renewed call to praise so that all of of psalm one 17
follows this form.
Praise the Lord.
All you nations extol him all you peoples.
There's your invocation for greatest,
his steadfast love toward us.
The faithfulness of the Lord endures forever.
There's your motive clause.
Hallelujah.
Hallelu is Hebrew imperative.
Praise Yahweh,
short for Yahweh God.
So highly Lou Yang means praise God.
So it's a recapitulation of the call to praise the imperative.
Praise God.
It's classic,
tiny little,
but it has all of the elements of,
of the form of a,
of a,
of a psalm of thanksgiving,
some one 36 punctuates,
a recitation of God's great deeds,
the creation,
the exodus,
the conquest of the promised land and so on.
With the phrase,
his steadfast love is eternal.
It's an excellent illustration of how Israel's praise is inspired by remembering
what Yahweh has done in history.
Still other psalms extol God in his role as creator.
One Oh four is another one of those and we've already seen one or as law giver.
So there are various reasons to praise God creation.
His role in history has giving of the law.
Uh,
striking characteristic of this category of psalms is the variety of metaphors
that are used that are used to describe God.
King Shield,
stronghold,
rock refuge,
shelter.
Many more metaphors as well.
The pair of Sigmadek,
Psalm of trust is contained in the 23rd psalm.
This is a psalm that employs the metaphor of a shepherd to describe God,
guiding the individual and straight paths through a frightening valley.
The speakers trust creates a sense of tranquility,
even in the presence of enemies.
And here I'm going to use the RSB translation,
which would be more familiar to many of you.
The Lord is my shepherd.
I shall not want.
He makes me lie down in green pastures.
He leads me beside still waters.
He restores my soul.
He leads me in paths of righteousness for his sake.
Even though I walk through the Valley of the shadow of death,
I fear no evil for thou art with me,
thy Rod and thy staff,
they comfort me.
That preparest a table before me in the presence of my enemies though anointest
my head with oil,
my cup overflows.
Surely goodness and mercy shall follow me all the days of my life and I shall
dwell in the house of the Lord forever.
The short psalm one 31,
it's another psalm of trust that invokes the image of a mother and a child to
express an even greater tranquility in the RSV translation.
Oh God,
my heart is not lifted up.
My eyes are not raised too high.
That's a metaphor for arrogance in Hebrew.
I do not occupy myself with things too great and too marvelous for me,
but I have calmed and quieted my soul like a child quieted at it's mother's
breast,
like a child that has quieted is my soul.
Oh Israel hope in the Lord from this time forth and forevermore.
So these and similar psalms contained some of the most personal depictions of
biblical faith,
have confidence or simple trust in God.
The second category I've got listed,
therefore you are psalms of divine kingship or royal psalms.
Um,
these are not quite the same.
They're two distinct things.
Um,
and thrown mint or kingship.
Psalms celebrate halfway as the enthroned ruler,
the sovereign ruler of the heavens,
and as sovereign over foreign nations,
so sovereign over nature,
sovereign over the human world and their descriptions of God employ the language
and themes that are associated with the deities of ancient near eastern
mythology,
particularly the bow,
um,
the,
uh,
the language associated with bile,
the Canaanite storm God,
some even allude to the defeat of a sea monster as key to God's role as creator
and enthroned king.
In Psalm 29,
the assembly of the God's praises.
Yeah,
way for defeating the water monster.
And although some psalms fully personify nature at the time of creation in
others,
the old ancient near eastern combat creation myths are d.
So we see both of these tendencies within some of these psalms.
So for example,
some 93,
the Lord is king,
he is robed in Grand Europe,
most of these and throw them in or divine kingship.
Psalms,
we'll begin with the Lord is king,
the Lord is king.
He is robed and rancher.
The Lord is robed.
He was girded with strength.
The world stands from.
It cannot be shaken.
Your throne stands from,
from of old,
from eternity.
You have existed.
The ocean sounds o Lord,
the ocean sounds,
it's thunder.
The ocean sounds,
it's pounding above the funder of the mighty waters,
more majestic than the breakers of the sea.
Is the Lord Majestic on high your decrees or indeed and during holiness be fits
your house.
Oh Lord,
for all times.
See here the mention of the sea,
the ocean pounding,
but it's completely de mythologized did appears here as a natural and an entity
and not a divine antagonist.
By contrast,
there are psalms in which God is battling with a c in the form of a monster.
While Psalms are psalms that praise God's anointed king.
Some scholars believe that these were coronation psalms.
These would have been used at the time of the coronation of a Davidic king,
for example.
So some one 10 the yogic way said to my Lord my Lord,
now meaning the King Yahoo,
I said to my Lord,
sit at my right hand while I make your enemies your footstool.
The Lord will stretch forth from Xy on your mighty septor hold sway over your
enemies,
your people come forward willingly on your day of battle.
I guess that's what every king wishes for your people come forward willingly on
your day of battle and majestic holiness from the womb,
from the dawn.
Yours was the do of youth.
The Lord has sworn and will not relent.
You are a priest forever.
A rightful king by my decree.
The Lord is at your right hand.
Yeah,
is at your right hand.
He crushes kings in the day of his anger,
but not all of the Royal Psalms were concerned primarily with military success
or guaranteeing military success.
Some seek to ensure that the king,
the anointed king is bestowed with,
uh,
other qualities necessary for good stewardship.
And so we find in Psalm 72 oh God,
endow the king with your judgments that King's son with your righteousness,
that he may judge your people rightly,
your lowly ones justly.
Let him champion the lowly among the people.
Deliver the needy folk and crush those who wrong them.
Let them be like rain.
That falls on a Moen field like a downpour of rain on the ground,
that the righteous may flourish in his time and wellbeing.
A bound till the moon is no more.
A third category I've got listed for you are psalms of lament and petition and
indebtedness,
and these can be voiced in the plural,
a communal supplication or in the voice of the individual.
Although individual laments may open with an invocation to um,
or praise of God,
some launch immediately into a desperate plea for deliverance from some
suffering or crisis.
It's often expressed metaphorically or they might launch into a plea of for
vengeance on one's enemies.
After presenting his complaint,
the psalmist will usually confess his trust in God,
then ask for help or forgiveness and conclude with a vow that he will praise God
again and we sometimes even see an acknowledgement of a divine response.
Perhaps a thank you in advance.
Some 13 has many of these features.
How long o Lord will you ignore me forever?
How long will you hide your face from me?
How long will I have cares on my mind?
Grief in my heart all day?
How long will my enemy have?
The upper hand look at me,
answer me,
o Lord,
my God,
restore the luster to my eyes lest I sleep the sleep of death,
lest my enemies say I have overcome him.
My foes exalt in your deliverance.
I will sing to the Lord for he has been good to me.
Psalm 55 asks for deliverance from the treachery of a deceitful friend.
It is not an enemy who reviles me.
I could bear that it is not my foe who Vaughn's himself against me.
I could hide from him,
but it is you.
My equal,
my companion,
my friend sweet was our fellowship.
We walked together in God's house.
Let him insight death against them.
May they go down alive and just shake.
Oh for where they dwell.
Evil is he harmed his ally.
He broke his,
packed his talk with smoother than butter.
Yet his mind was on war.
His words were more soothing than oil,
yet they were drawn swords.
Cast your burden upon the Lord and he shall sustain you.
He will never let the righteous man collapse.
Very personalized.
Um,
laments supplements are pleased for forgiveness of personal sins.
This one is attributed in the psalm itself.
At that the,
the superscription to the Somme.
It's attributed to David after the Prophet Nathan rebukes him for his illicit
relationship with Best Sheva.
And listen to the striking parallelism.
You hear the poetic parallelism in this psalm.
Psalm 51 again,
using the RSV translation,
have mercy on me.
O God,
according to thy steadfast love,
according to thy abundant mercy,
blot out my transgressions.
Wash me thoroughly from my iniquity,
and cleanse me from my sin.
For I know my transgressions and my sin is ever before me,
against thee only have I sinned and done that which is evil in thy sight so that
thou aren't justified in I sentence and blameless and I judgment created me a
clean heart,
oh God.
And put a new and right spirit within me.
Cast me not away from thy presence,
and take not thy Holy Spirit from me.
Restore to me the joy of thy salvation and uphold me with a willing spirit.
But communal,
lament,
slander.
These are individual but communal laments,
but whale Israel's misfortunes and urge God's vengeance upon Israel suppressors,
sometimes reminding God of his historic relationship with Israel and his
covenantal obligations.
Let me just finish by reading.
Psalm 74 is a case in point.
It makes explicit reference to the destruction of the sanctuary,
so it's clearly postings Zelig and as a response to the catastrophe,
it gives expression to despair and be wilderness and even anger that God has
forgotten his obligations to Israel.
Why?
Oh God,
do you forever reject us?
Do you fume and anger at the flock that you to remember the community you made
yours as long ago,
your very own tribe that you redeemed,
Mount Zion where you dwell,
be stir yourself because if the perpetual to mode two mouth,
all the outrageous of the enemy in the sanctuary,
your foes roar inside your meeting place,
they take their signs for true signs.
It's like men wielding acts as against a gnarled tree with hatchet and pike.
They hacked away at it's carved work.
They made your sanctuary go up in flames.
They brought low and dishonor the dwelling place of your presence.
They resolved.
Let us destroy them all together.
They burned all God's tabernacles in the land.
No signs appear for us.
There is no longer any profit.
No one among us who knows for how long till when?
Oh God,
will the enemy forever revile your name.
Why do you hold back your hand,
your right hand,
draw it out of your bosom.
Do not deliver your dove to the wild beast.
Do not ignore forever the band of your lowly ones.
Look to the covenant rise.
Oh God.
Champion your cause.
The psalmist is be Willard.
Why has this happened?
Why doesn't God Act?
There's no mention of Israel sin.
There is no indication that the destruction was just punishment.
And Psalm 44 which we'll start with next time,
goes even further and states flatly that the people haven't sinned.
It's God who's been faithless.